tonight the cdc showing 40 percent of
americans are fully vaccinated but the
push to boost that number continues
several states have turned to lotteries
with big payouts
to get people to get the shots nevada
has not done that
but we wanted to know what it would take
to convince someone still
unsure sasha loftis found out where
people stand on this trend
sasha denise and brian
reactions to this were certainly mixed
some say they are all for those
incentives and ideas while others tell
me
they are still on the fence about this
incentives for immunizations it's
getting people vaccinated
maybe we're on the fence from free lap
dances here in las vegas to
a jackpot lottery in ohio enticing
offers are sweeping the nation by storm
take advantage of the incentives that
we're offering so we asked people here
in the valley
if they'd get vast for a prize i think
it's a really great idea
i feel like people love the incentive i
don't think it's worth the risk the
reaction may be mixed but nearby states
keep bringing bonuses to the table 2
million
incentive cards on a first come first
served basis
for individuals that are eligible to get
a vaccine
this includes california as governor
gavin newsom announced thursday
he's setting aside more than 100 million
dollars
to push for more shots in arms let them
say they're getting some
out of the deal it's an effort many
experts are on board with
as they advocate for the safety of
others
i just feel like really everybody's best
interest is to
get vaccinated and that coveted
transition
to post pandemic life whether it's
fraiser
johnson and johnson get the vaccine
now if you still need to get your
vaccine here in the valley we do have a
list of all the available locations
that's on our website
8newsnow.com and a reminder if you do
again need to get that vaccine whether
it is pfizer moderna or johnson and
johnson
it is completely free reporting live in
las vegas tonight sasha loftis
8 news now